well it's been another weekend I hope everybody's
weekend was good here in the United States we had
11 mass shootings this weekend and more than
300 shootings altogether those are the right
numbers do not adjust your television do not
punch your phone screen do not throw it in the
toilet and flush it those are the real numbers 11
mass shootings Friday to Sunday and more than 300
shootings total in terms of the mass shootings we
had four on Friday three on Saturday and four on
Sunday now understand that in the U.S we have
categories of shootings that don't exist in
the entire world you look at Serbia for example
and what recently happened there with shootings
and you see that there are categories here that
would sound crazy Elsewhere for example in the
United States we have regular shootings not mass
shootings where one or two people are killed or
injured and many that's a regular shooting you
then have mass shootings where you have three
people injured or killed in total or more and then
you have nationally uh uh covered mass shootings
which are mass shootings that the country takes
an interest in interest in and indeed uh but by
the way if you're interested about these numbers
go to gunviolencearchive.org you can see the mass
shootings you can see all shootings over the last
72 hours for example you know this morning there
have already been shootings in Los Angeles to in
Texas this uh or I'm sorry one in Texas was this
morning one was yesterday okay so you you kind
of get the picture some of these make National
headlines for example the one in Allen Texas did
this was at the Allen Premium Outlets where eight
victims were killed seven were injured and the
shooter was quote neutralized for a report by
Fox 4 that one received extensive coverage many
politicians weighing in about it we'll dig into
that one in more detail a little bit later but
then there are other mass shootings that get
less attention for example there was the one in St
Louis Missouri where two teens were killed and two
others were injured this was yesterday morning
Sunday morning this one got local coverage but
didn't really get National coverage that's because
in the United States Mass shoot not just shootings
are so common mass shootings are so common that
it's got to be really depraved and deranged like
particularly sick to even make National headlines
and again that's just mass shootings then we have
just kind of like your run-of-the-mill shootings
for example these these aren't even a blip on the
radar for most of the country uh this one was in
Pendleton Indiana where a man was found shot to
death and police are seeking The public's help
this this is sort of like you're more pedestrian
mass shooting for lack of a better term so this is
the day-to-day reality in the United States and we
continue to have and we're going to delve into
this we continue to have a political contingent
that wants to do nothing other than offer prayers
sometimes thoughts sometimes they will think about
it but often it's just they'll pray sometimes
thoughts and prayers sometimes just prayers
and uh when I suggested of course on Twitter
that the prayer doesn't really seem to help
even even Christian schools have been shot up and
certainly there's prayer happening there I'm the
bad guy rather than all the people who want to do
absolutely nothing we then have elected officials
who choose instead to focus on Mental Health yet
they don't want to fund Mental Health Services
or they want to focus on violent video games
even when there's no evidence that the shooter
played video games you've all gotten to know this
endless routine that we have in the United States
another aspect to the cycle of course the sick
Insidious cycle is right when there's a major
again I'm using the crazy terminology when we have
a major mass shooting of natural interest National
interest we should have an abbreviation for that
uh there are many people who say now that this is
again in the spotlight as it is every few days we
should really do something about gun safety laws
and these are very popular proposals we saw even
a Fox News poll last week said that most Americans
favor requiring a background check in every
case of a gun transaction even between private
individuals but these things are very popular
oh we can't politicize this in the immediate
aftermath tensions are running High the families
haven't buried their debt you hear all this stuff
but we do send our thoughts and prayers either
you thoughts and prayers you can do at any time
and then a little while goes by and then hopefully
the people seeking to make change hopefully I mean
from the perspective of the gun people the people
seeking to make change forget or they move on or
whatever the case may be and then nothing happens
and then we have our next major mass shooting of
national interest and then same cycle over and
over and over again I have to tell you though we
did hear from a few people after the shooting
in Allen Texas who were stepping out of their
you might call it their prescribed uh
characters and actually said things
that make a lot of sense I want to look at
a couple examples of this with you right now